one of the one of my
more recent hobby horses within the last
like six months or so
is uh
looking at the effects of range of
motion on hypertrophy um
because i there's a lot of
i i mean there has been for several
years a lot of just like chatter in the
evidence-based fitness community about
how
uh full range of motion training through
a full range of motion is very important
for hypertrophy
and i kind of don't think that full
range of motion matters all that much
i think that when people talk about the
benefits of full range of motion
training for muscle growth i think
ultimately they're just picking up on
the benefits of ensuring that your reps
do include the portion of the rep that
involves
muscular tension and long muscle links
but i don't think the range of motion is
all that important per se so for example
um
if you're doing something that has a
where full range of motion is 120
degrees at a particular joint
i think that the benefits of training
through a full range of motion rather
than a partial range of motion
is that when people talk about partials
they tend to just be talking about the
top half of the range of motion so for
example if you're doing bench press
you lock the bar out between every rep
but you only go midway down to your
chest um so when people talk about
partials they think about something like
that or like half squats for example
um
and so when you're using that as your
model of partial range of motion
training what you do tend to find is
that full range of motion training uh
improves outcomes so training all the
way from zero degrees of flexion to 120.
uh but i i kind of think that if you
just train from 120 degrees to 60
degrees and cut out the top part kind of
the classic um
constant tension training approach i
think that's just as good as training
through a full range of motion
because ultimately i think it's less
that
just the total angular displacement at
each joint matters and it's more so
um
ensuring that you are
training through the part with long
muscle links and i kind of think the
part where you're training through short
muscle lengths um
you know just has a neutral effect so
whether or not you lock out each rep
doesn't really matter all that much so
with uh with that introduction out of
the way i reviewed uh
two studies in mass this past year that
are directly relevant to that
so the title of the first one was
partial range of motion training might
increase muscle growth parentheses if
you do the right type of partials so
this was a study by pedrosa and
colleagues the title was partial range
of motion training elicits favorable
improvements in muscular adaptations
when carried out at long muscle lengths
so in this study uh
five groups of untrained women
completed a 12-week training protocol
one of the groups was a non-training
control group
and then the other four groups
trained knee extensions for 12 weeks so
one of the groups did all of their reps
through a full range of motion
one of the groups did all of their reps
through a partial range of motion uh in
a
decent bit of knee flexion so basically
the bottom half of the range of motion
which
uh coincides with long muscle lengths
for the quadriceps
one group did partials but just through
the top half of the range of motion so
the part of the range of motion that
would have uh that would be through
short muscle links of the quadriceps one
group did vary the partial range of
motion so they did half of their reps
partials at long muscle links half of
them partials at short muscle lengths
and the final group was uh just a full
range of motion group where they you
know did full range of motion reps uh so
they trained for 12 weeks and they
looked at growth of the vastus lateralis
and rectus femoris at
three different sites so or four
different sites so from a proximal site
at forty percent of femur length so
that's uh if you go from the hip to the
knee uh starting at the hip going down
forty percent of femur length that was
the most proximal site and then seventy
percent of femur links so closer to the
knee that was the most distal site
um
so yeah uh
there were
i mean there there were a shitload of
pairwise comparisons here but the the
broad strokes are that
um
the
partial range of motion at long muscle
lengths group had overall the best
hypertrophy response uh of all of the
four training groups and and certainly
better than the control group
um
but but that group the full range of
motion group and the variable range of
motion partial group uh all had pretty
solid hypertrophy outcomes the partial
range of motion group just training at
short muscle links uh tended to grow
quite a bit less than the other three
groups particularly in the distal parts
of the muscle so
the 40 and 50 percent of femur length
sites the more the more proximal parts
tended to grow pretty well in all of the
groups but then the more distal sites
tended to grow the best in the three
groups that did involve training at long
muscle links um
and like i mentioned the
group that
just did partials at long muscle lengths
got at least as good of hypertrophy
results as any of the other groups and
arguably better than any of the other
groups so that that was some uh
direct evidence that the range of motion
through which you're training partials
matters a lot and that if you're doing
the partials at long muscle links they
may actually produce slightly more
hypertrophy than training just through a
full range of motion
and then there was a a more recent study
um
by
sato and colleagues that i just reviewed
last month
elbow joint angles in elbow flexor
unilateral resistance exercise training
determine its effects
on muscle strength and thickness of
trained and non-trained arms so in this
study subjects did unilateral preacher
curls uh there wasn't a full range of
motion group in this study it was just
partials at long muscle links versus
partials at short muscle links uh and
subjects were doing unilateral preacher
curls
and and the findings were very similar
so they had three different measurement
sites here uh 50 60 and 70 of humorous
length overall hypertrophy was greater
in the group doing partials at long
muscle lengths in the group doing
partials at short muscle lengths
and the magnitude of difference
increased as you moved towards more
distal sites along the muscle
um and then when averaging all three
sites together the group doing the lung
the long muscle length partials
experience like 2.6 times more
hypertrophy than the group doing short
muscle length partials
so again not a direct comparison in that
study to full range of motion training
but
very clear evidence that not all
partials are created equal
partials at short muscle links tend to
not cause as much growth overall and in
particular there's a pretty big
difference at distal muscle sites so
like for example if you wanted uh and
and this is gonna depend to some degree
on like tendon length and overall muscle
architecture but kind of like in a
vacuum if you just want like a big like
freaky horseshoe tricep that hangs over
your elbow or just like big freaky
quads that like
look like they're about to swallow up
your knees
those are distal muscle sites and and
training through long muscle links tends
to be very important uh for growth in
those sites
and there's also uh
more evidence just from isometric
training that you know not even doing
reps but just tension per se at long
muscle links um
tends to promote uh hypertrophy quite
well so there was a a systematic review
by oren chuck and colleagues i think in
2019
isometric training and long-term
adaptations effects of muscle length
intensity and intent a systematic review
and one of the things they looked at in
that systematic review was isometric
training at long versus short muscle
links finding that uh
hypertrophy tended to be quite a bit
greater when you did isometric training
at long muscle lengths than short
um
and there there's also evidence i think
that
uh
including the part of the range of
motion that coincides with short
muscling so essentially locking out
every rep um
maybe doesn't matter all that much and
could potentially be
slightly harmful for hypertrophy
and i think that probably depends on
whether kind of the lockout position
does
keep you under tension or not but there
was a study by goto and colleagues
looking at triceps growth with a partial
range of motion versus full range of
motion
barbell tricep extensions basically
skull crushers
one of the groups trained through a full
range of motion so from zero to 120
degrees of elbow flexion one of the
groups
did partials just through the mid-range
of motion so
at the bottom they stopped at 90 degrees
of elbow flexion and then they went up
to 45 degrees of elbow flexion but they
didn't actually lock the reps out
and in that study
i
they didn't assess hypertrophy i think
in the most
using using gold standard methods they
used a regression equation based on
uh arm circumferences and skin fold
thicknesses which
so it's been done but yeah it's it's not
the best way to assess hypertrophy so
take it with a slight grain of salt but
they they did find that
estimates of tricep cross-sectional area
derived from arm circumference and skin
fold thicknesses
increased to to a greater extent in the
group that basically skipped lockout uh
even though they didn't actually go down
as far into elbow flexion on each rep so
i think that
when you kind of triangulate all of that
um
i i would definitely like to see
more direct comparisons uh specifically
between
long muscle length partials and full
range of motion before i could make any
sort of definitive statement
because currently we do just have one
study making that direct direct
comparison
and it's looking at just single joint
exercises in untrained individuals so
you know you probably don't want to put
too many eggs in that basket but i think
that there are
several different lines of evidence that
one could point to to to say that
you know at worst
um
partials threw a longer partials uh at
in in long muscle length positions
rather than short muscle length
positions uh
i think you can say at worst that's
going to cause more hypertrophy than
partials just through short muscle
length positions you know kind of for
now discounting the comparison to full
range of motion training so i think we
can very confidently say not all
partials are created equal
um but i do i do kind of think that
uh if you do like quote unquote constant
tension training you do partials but the
part of the range of motion you're
cutting out is like the lockout portion
the short muscle length portion uh
i kind of think that you're going to
grow just as much as you would from
doing full range of motion training and
possibly slightly more um
and another thing i'll note is that when
when we talk about uh
when we talk about the effects of range
of motion on hypertrophy i think it's
also
worth nuancing that just a little bit
uh so the the differences don't seem to
be
um kind of evenly dispersed across the
length of a muscle so if you compare
kind of quote unquote normal partial
range of motion training so you know now
we're talking half squats bench presses
that don't touch your chest etc
um when we look at that type of partial
compared to
either long muscle length partials or
full range of motion training in studies
that assess hypertrophy at multiple
different muscle sites what they tend to
find is that for more proximal muscle
sites
you actually seem to grow about the same
amount regardless of range of motion so
you know if you're assessing changes in
quad size closer to the hip or changes
in
tricep size closer to the shoulder for
example um seems like those proximal
sites tend to grow pretty well
regardless of how you're training but
that uh either partials at long muscle
links or full range of motion training
that includes training at long muscle
links that tends to be pretty essential
for fully growing more distal parts of
the muscle so overall full range of
motion training does beat short muscle
length partials but the
the uh
effects aren't evenly distributed across
the muscle there there is that regional
component which
i personally think is kind of cool
yeah i mean
i suspect that some
people at my gym kind of suspect that
i'm a dumbass
and the reason is
i think
i think some people
struggle to warm up to the idea of
partials at short uh i'm sorry partials
at long muscle lengths well they also
think you're a dumb ass because
you thought that
simply the fact that a magnet wouldn't
stick to you immediately after you got a
vaccine
negated their argument that vaccines
would stick to you immediately after you
got a vaccine i'm not sure if we ever
actually mentioned that on the show we
did for sure okay
so that that's a throwback uh at first i
was like i don't think anyone has
context for that no but um i think some
people struggle to warm up to this idea
of partials at long muscle lengths
because
uh back in the day you would call that
cheating right so like for example a lot
of times i'll be doing bicep curls this
is one of the areas where i use a little
bit of this but i'll do full range of
motion bicep curls until i can no longer
and then i will do a few extra reps at
the end of doing partial range of motion
and it'll be up to that sticking point
which is you know i'm training
exclusively at longer uh muscle lengths
for for those partials and so i think
the the typical person passing by would
say look at this jackass who's counting
these reps and he's like not even
getting halfway up
but it's it's intentional uh and i think
you know like you said i don't know if
it's necessarily doing too much but like
it's a nice little supplementary thing
to help me get a little bit more effort
into that set is it going to pay off big
time i don't know but i do similar
things depending on you know what i'm
trying to accomplish in the set but
sometimes i'll do similar things for
like a dumbbell incline press i'll do
full range of motion until i'm kind of
struggling uh at that kind of sticking
point in the middle then i'll get some
nice loaded stretches i'll keep
everything at the longer muscle lengths
for my pecs and get a few extra reps to
really uh to really grind out the set
and so i think the typical passerby
would say those reps don't count that
guy's a jackass but then
i take off my top layer and i'm wearing
a stringer and they say holy [ __ ] that
looks like the kind of guy that is so
muscular
that it would hold him back at the
professional bodybuilding level didn't
even have been able to win the 1991 miss
olympia they would have given it to
someone less muscular that's what they
think so but when i'm not when i'm not
wearing a stringer and i have bulky
clothing on i don't think they can tell
you know but anyway i use a little bit
of this partial range of motion stuff
and it's pretty nice i like it sweet
uh the the area where where i've always
used it is uh dumbbell flies like i've
talked about my love of the pec deck
machine on this podcast several times
before but i'm training in my basement
now uh you know just have dumbbells
don't have a pec deck don't have room
for a pec deck if i did i'd definitely
get a peck dad uh but anyway i
indeed you don't need a whole kitchen
just get rid of part of your kitchen and
put it on absolutely not um but yeah i
know so i i like peck training i think
that um
i think that i'm the only maybe the only
person in the world who has a pec
dominant pull-up like when you're when
your arms are when your arms are above
your head
your pecs do have slight shoulder
extension functionality and uh
when i'm
good at pull-ups like when i've been
doing pull-ups somewhat frequently and i
can do a decent number in a set
i always get an enormous pec pump from
pull-ups like i i think i get a a bigger
pec pump than lat pump um
anyway i i think that just about every
upper body exercise i do somehow turns
out to be peck dominant uh so i i like
pec training i just think it's fun
and so when i do dumbbell flies
i and
i'm man this goes back to when i was
like 12 years old and i was first
introduced to the exercise
um
like i was doing like full range of
motion
dumbbell pec flies on a bench in the
local ymca
um
and this older gentleman comes up to me
and he said
you want me to teach you how to do flies
and this guy i think i may have
mentioned him on the podcast before he
was one of my first training partners i
had two very fun training partners at
that ymca one of them was this guy i'm
about to mention the other one was a
bounty hunter and um
his name wasn't dog was it his name
i [ __ ] you this wasn't his real name but
everyone referred to him as cornbread
um
cornbread the bounty hunter
[Laughter]
uh if we ever do merchandise we have to
have a cornbread the bounty hunter
character yeah uh anyway both excellent
training partners they taught me a lot
and also they they both had uh excellent
stories
but anyway um
completely neglecting the stories for
now this was this was my first
introduction to this older gentleman
and he was in his
either late 60s or early 70s but still
had
he he still had a very solid physique um
and yeah he he he could tell that i
didn't really know what i was doing so
he's like you want me to teach you how
to really do peck flies and i said okay
sure absolutely i would love to learn
uh
and so
he i think one of the reasons why i'm
kind of open to the whole idea of long
muscle length partials is that's all
this guy did um
like you know he would do he would do
weighted pull-ups again like in his late
60s early 70s he'd have like
a either a plate or a plate and a 25
hanging off of him but he'd only do like
a seven inch range of motion like by the
time the top of his head was level with
the bar he was done concentric was over
time to go back down i actually liked
that as well uh and he he approached
everything the same way so like you know
he'd do dumbbell press go all the way
down at the bottom
push it up about four inches go back
down like that that's how he approached
all of his training um so anyway he
taught me that method of pec flies like
go down until you get a deep stretch
go up
until
like you still feel a lot of tension on
the muscle but it's not acutely
stretched anymore and then just go back
down so we're talking pec flies through
maybe a six inch range of motion yeah
and
like i've done flies before because i'd
seen them in a magazine and someone big
said this is a good exercise uh
but like that was the first time that
the next day my pecs felt
absolutely destroyed i was like hell
yeah this is how i do flies now and i've
always done that like i i never go all
the way up on flies um and i think that
that's probably in a pretty extreme
example
just because the mechanical leverage is
so low at the bottom and so high at the
top but i think a similar principle
can apply to most exercises you do